over the years jonah hill has matured
from a comedy staple to a respected
actor with two oscar nominations but
he's also taken a few steps back from
the spotlight
here's why you may not have seen much of
him recently
despite his recent lack of face time
hill has still been busy bulking up his
acting resume
even if you haven't actually seen him
there's a good chance you've heard him
in one of the animated projects he's
lent his voice to
hill's most recent live-action roles
have been confined to the small screen
his last appearance was his cameo as
himself in hbo's curb your enthusiasm in
2020
and he hasn't had a leading role since
starring in netflix's maniac in 2018.
in the time between however hill lent
his voice to two animated sequel films
he reprised his role as snotlout in how
to train your dragon the hidden world
and made another appearance as green
lantern in the lego movie 2
the second part of course voice acting
is nothing new to hell as he first went
behind the microphone for the role of
tommy in the 2008 adaptation
of the dr seuss classic horton hears a
who he's also played a foul-mouthed hot
dog in the notoriously raunchy sausage
party and the super-powered titan
in megamind there is no easter bunny
there is no tooth fairy
and there is no queen of england in 2019
hill had a supporting role in harmony
karine's flick the beach bum
as lewis the bombastic agent of
hedonistic poet moondog played by
matthew mcconaughey
karine known for unsettling movies such
as gummo and spring breakers
is a polarizing director and reviews for
the beach bum certainly reflected that
public reception for the film was mixed
and most critics found it somewhere
between mediocre and middling in his
review for the guardian peter bradshaw
wrote writer director harmony karine
achieves a zen state of unfunny with
this pointless non-comedy
this can only provoke something like awe
that something so awful can still get
made
the beach bum underperformed at the box
office and wasn't exactly in the running
for any
academy awards with so many great films
already on hill's resume
the beach bum doesn't necessarily stand
out as a prime example of his work
so he didn't receive much publicity for
the few scenes in which he appears when
all was said and done however he may be
thankful for that
if you were to ask hill which role he
was the most proud of there's a good
chance he would tell you it was his part
in the 2018 gus
van sant biopic don't worry he won't get
far on foot
hill played donnie green the alcoholics
anonymous sponsor for joaquin phoenix's
john callahan
a man left quadriplegic after a drunk
driving accident who regains his
strength by drawing irreverent cartoons
although hill loved working on the film
and looks back on it as a highlight of
his career he was frustrated with the
lackluster marketing campaign the movie
received he expressed disappointment
with amazon studios for not properly
promoting the film telling gq
it's the best acting i have done or will
ever do but no one saw it
critics generally enjoy don't worry he
won't get far on foot which stands at a
77 percent fresh rating on rotten
tomatoes in her review for the evening
standard critic charlotte o'sullivan
wrote
basically you can't take your eyes off
hell and you get the feeling that
phoenix can't either
that gravitational pull is exactly right
for the story
donnie rearranges john's universe the
path to enlightenment is to know
yourself
how do i know myself forget yourself
if you're a fan of the dc universe you
may remember rumors that hill was slated
to appear in warner brothers newest
iteration of the caped crusader
matt reeves the batman hill was
allegedly lined up to play a villain in
the film opposite robert pattinson
as bruce wayne while warner brothers
never confirmed which villain hill was
in talks to portray
rumor had it that he was being
considered for the role of oswald
cobblepot
otherwise known as the penguin however
hill's talks with the studio
ultimately did not lead to a part in the
film and the news broke that hill was no
longer in consideration for the role
instead the movie has moved along with
colin farrell as the penguin
paul dano as the riddler and zoe
kravitz's catwoman the last of which
hill was almost certainly never
considered to play the batman recently
wrapped filming and is scheduled to be
released in 2022
hill has no intentions of giving up
acting but has been interested in
writing and directing since his
childhood today he's taking on
projects that give him the chance to get
behind the camera hill has experimented
with writing and directing before
he wrote for the short-lived tv series
alan gregory in 2011
and contributed to the storylines for
both jump street movies he has served as
a producer on films like richard jewell
and the documentary beastie boys story
hill has also directed multiple music
videos
including vampire weekend sunflower and
travis scott's wake up in 2018
hill made his childhood dreams come true
when he wrote and directed his own film
the coming-of-age comedy drama mid-90s
the movie tells the story of stevie
a 13 year old with a troubled home life
who finds a sense of brotherhood with a
group of skateboarders in la
mid-90s received positive reviews from
critics and chances seem good that hill
will attempt to direct another film in
the future while such efforts behind the
camera may interfere with acting
opportunities hill seems intent on
branching out
hill has never been shy about his sense
of style and several years ago he
decided that he wanted to start his very
own clothing line before he could even
begin the process however
adidas reached out to him and offered
the opportunity to collaborate on a
collection in an interview discussing
the launch with gq
hill said it was like of course i'm
going to learn from these geniuses and
collaborate with them who wouldn't take
that opportunity
and to get your stuff worn and seen by
more people and also have a great
education
he'll put his personal apparel ideas on
hold with plans to later reply lessons
learned from adidas towards future
efforts as a clothier he explained that
the design process was
time-consuming hill began officially
collaborating with adidas and working on
the line
two years before was released to the
public in 2020
now that he's wrapped up the work on his
adidas collection though he's free to
pursue his dream of starting his own
clothing lot
hill has had multiple unfortunate
interactions with the press that have
left him feeling less than enthused
known to clash with the paparazzi in
public hill makes it no secret when he
thinks someone is being too nosy into
his private life
ever president hill's life has been the
issue of his weight a media
preoccupation that has impacted his
self-confidence
while he hopes that people understand
his worst interactions with the press
don't represent who he really is hill
admits that he's exasperated with public
scrutiny in an instagram post responding
to paparazzi photos of him at the beach
being published in the daily mail
hill wrote i don't think i ever took my
shirt off in a pool until i was in my
mid-30s even in front of family and
friends
probably would have happened sooner if
my childhood insecurities weren't
exacerbated by years of public mockery
about my body by press and interviewers
when you consider the toll that such
statements can have on someone who spent
over a decade in the public
eye it's no wonder that hill prefers to
maintain strong boundaries between his
personal and professional life
hill is an undeniably funny actor having
made audiences laugh for years
often at his own expense but despite
receiving pressure to appear in more
comedies
hill is much pickier about the roles he
accepts today and makes it clear that he
doesn't want to continue
playing the same characters for the rest
of his career hill told indy wire
i love those films but i also think that
if you look back at those films
a lot of what they're showing is major
bro comedy and bro masculinity
hill is open to passing up comedies to
pursue more serious roles he's also on
the lookout for opportunities to work
with female directors
having told the guardian it's insane
that my perspective as an actor has only
been a male's vision
perhaps hill won't be on screen as much
as he used to be simply because he's
being more selective
but his future roles will certainly be
worth keeping an eye on
hill is very close with his family his
sister beanie feldstein has appeared in
films like lady bird and book booksmart
and his brother jordan feldstein managed
to ban maroon 5.
however tragedy struck hill's family in
2017
when jordan unexpectedly passed away
after suffering a pulmonary embolism at
just 40 years old hill was devastated by
his brother's passing and in the
aftermath of jordan's death he preferred
to maintain his privacy rather than
speaking to the press about his loss
however his sister beanie published an
essay in in style titled grief glasses
in which she described her experience of
grief as wearing a pair of glasses that
she couldn't take off
she wrote and these glasses make me see
the world differently than i did before
the colors bleed together more vividly
but they are somehow more than they ever
were before
more visceral more vibrant more present
simultaneously more awe-inspiring and
more aching
hill has appeared in plenty of films
produced by hollywood's most storied
studios but while actors can benefit
from working on tentpole films the
paycheck in publicity comes with a lot
of pressure
as hill continues his pivot to working
on passion projects
and trying his hand at writing and
directing he has increasingly realized
that putting out a film with a big
studio just
isn't always worth it in an interview
with vulture hill said that he now
prefers to work with smaller studios
because he doesn't like to deal with the
expectation to quote make a bajillion
dollars and be so mainstream
that's why he chose to release mid 90s
with a24
a smaller independent studio known for
distributing critically acclaimed flicks
like moonlight and the lighthouse the
way hill sees it
working with a24 gave him the freedom to
depict the story he wanted to tell in
mid-90s without compromising his
artistic vision
if you're looking forward to seeing hill
on screen again you're in luck
he has been hard at work on the upcoming
netflix political satire don't look up
written and directed by adam mckay of
vice and the big short fame the film
features an a-list cast
led by leonardo dicaprio and jennifer
lawrence as a pair of astronomers who
try to warn earth about an
approaching asteroid only to discover
that society is less receptive to their
efforts than they had hoped
hill is reportedly playing the son and
chief of staff of meryl streep's
president of the united states like many
other projects production on the film
was intermittently delayed in 2020
because of covert 19 regulations however
don't look up is currently expected to
get a release in late 2021 and with a
cast that includes plenty of big names
it seems likely to get plenty of major
attention
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you